Legacy's has got fans talking they've
come up with some pretty mind-blowing
theories about landon hope and malov or
go away evil one already gone we've put
together the most popular legacies
theories that all fans should see so
keep watching landings origin and
purpose so it's clear that landon is
definitely supernatural he can't be
compelled and since he doesn't seem to
possess even a hint of magic his lineage
is questionable we also know that he was
conceived in malov or which pretty much
sounds like hell that's easier said than
done
according to Reddit user Mellie be - - -
this fan wonders if malov or as an
entity got Cielo pregnant this would
make Landon a half-demon Mellie be - - -
thinks that Landon was conceived with a
destiny to release the monsters and
unconsciously destroy malov or reddit
user little liberty 95 added that Landon
also showed zero magic in his bloodline
which fans are convinced will soon
change this fan also pointed out that
Alaric said most people have at least a
little bit of magic in them he seemed to
be the only pure human although now we
know that can't be true so the
million-dollar question is what is he
you know the drill yeah keep my head
down make myself useful don't pick
fights exactly was he immaculately
conceived in a dark realm where no other
creature could resist a fan who goes by
a glare Aneta pointed out that Landon's
father was able to somehow reach Sayla
and create landon who she dubbed jesus
skywalker another fan has a different
theory altogether Manik won 2-6 believes
that Landon is the son of Hades who's
the creator of malov or interesting this
type in our theory
reddit user Dredd doctor has a pretty
insightful theory about the power of
siphon errs we all know that Cypress can
siphon magic from witches werewolves
vampires magic spells and objects but
what if their abilities go further than
this
if the episode where Josie kisses wrath
we know that siphon errs can use other
parts of their bodies besides just their
hands to siphon magic since this is the
case then theoretically they can type in
just about any magic that is cast on
them if you think about it they come in
direct contact with the magic that would
make them invincible against witches
because well
they can just siphon any spells or hexes
a witch uses since it would basically be
touching them dread doctor thinks that
since vampires and werewolves were both
created by magic maybe siphon errs are
able to steal magic from them this fan
references the case of the heretics in
The Vampire Diaries when they were able
to siphon from their vampire sides so
maybe they could remove the vampire and
werewolf curse it kind of makes sense if
a siphon art can siphon magic from a
vampire then could they take it all
leaving the vampire as a mortal human so
maybe the same is true for werewolves
however they would have to be pretty
quick to get away with it
merge theory Alaric had a book with the
ascendant drawn in along with Kai
Parker's mean I'm not here to hurt you
reddit user William den tenten's once
you know if Alaric is looking into
freeing Kai so that Lizzie and Josie can
merge with him instead of each other
would he even be able to merge twice
we've never seen to siphon hers merge so
it might not be possible William also
wonders which twin will do the merging
whoever does it gets Kai's personality
not to mention a bit of loot william
points out that Lizzie is crazy enough
as it is
so maybe Josie will be the one to do it
it seems they're teasing that merge will
happen but maybe not in season one
another Reddit user agreed saying they
think Kai is looking into how becoming a
heretic might save them this user points
out that when Kai ended his life
temporarily it ended the entire coven
with the exception of the twins and
other heretics Lizzie and Josie exists
to keep the coven alive but this user
believes that becoming a heretic could
save them with some notable downsides
the most obvious downside is that there
are still vampires which would make
Lizzie an unstoppable hot mess
come on guys let's go it's hero time
Damon and Elena starter fans of the
Vampire Diaries know that Damon and
Elena had a daughter named Stephanie
Salvatori but that's pretty much all
anybody knew but in the latest episode
of legacy Stephanie is mentioned then as
generous as he can be but he and Alena
have kids of their own that they need to
take care of here's what happened
Lizzie meets wish-granting Ginny and
which is that the Salvatori school never
existed
this Center into an alternate reality in
which she attends Mystic Falls High
School and is super unpopular Josie who
is the popular one asks Lizzy to steal
Alaric swatch to do its just get dad's
watch like you promised
she wants to sites in the power from it
she explains that the watch was given to
him by Stephenie Salvatore his dad
Stephanie Salvatore dad gave him the
watch who is most likely Damon Salvatore
II if you remember Damon was Alaric best
friend on the TV DS this got fans
talking one Reddit user I loved
bromances wrote that they made it seem
like Stephanie went to high school with
them but she couldn't be older than 11
he wrote that it's only been 12 years
since Elena woke up so that either makes
Stephanie a genius who skipped a lot of
grades in school or it's a convenient
way for writers to mention Stephanie's
names fans agree that the name Stephanie
is a tribute to Damon's brother Stefan
it makes sense that they would name
their child after the man who sacrificed
his own life so Damon and Elena could
live happily together odds are we'll
meet Stephanie Salvatori soon hopes fate
reddit user act hora asked fellow fans
what they think will happen once hope
dies she said everyone knows that when
hope dies she'll become a vampire but
will she still be a witch up to now
we've learned that bully siphon errs can
be both witches and vampires we also
know that any witch who becomes a
vampire loses their power so will hope
keep her powers once the vampire curse
is triggered legacies fans danger magnet
wrote that hope will probably be a
vampire-werewolf hybrid at the very
least this user mentions that we saw
hopes vampire side in episode 10 in the
first alternate universe since she's
branded as a tribrid it seems likely
that she'll maintain her unique status
and continue to be all three and
the Reddit user says that they think
there have been enough hints to deduce
that hope will still be a which hope
defies the odds being that she retained
her witch powers while still being a
werewolf this fan thinks that whatever
it is that makes first words of her
family so powerful is what will allow
her to retain her powers they believed
her to have magic that's powerful enough
to override the wolf purse and also
override the limitations of being a
vampire malibu key theory reddit users
SuperMario prose has a theory about the
keys
we know that hope remembers the whole
situation with say light even though no
one else does this is probably because
she's a tribe read this fan theory is
that since there are three keys it's
likely that the three supernatural races
work together to make them these would
of course be the witches the vampires
and the werewolves the theory is that
maybe other supernatural creatures cause
too much danger and need to be forgotten
or put down so a witch a vampire and a
wolf came together to use their blood or
some spell to create an incredibly
powerful law this would keep other
magical creatures locked up and
forgotten then each one would be
responsible for each of the three keys
the reason hope can remember is that she
is all three a witch a vampire and a
werewolf her being a tripod is something
none of them could have ever anticipated
when making the locks this user thinks
that Landon's father is one of the
banished creatures another fan wondered
why a vampire and wolf would work
together that's a fair question
reddit user met ginger seventeen replied
citing the logic the enemy of my enemy
is my friends it seems that the witches
hate both the wolves and the vampires so
this is a pretty solid theory since the
witches the vampires and the werewolves
are all basically humans with super
abilities it makes sense that they would
join forces to banish other potential
threats this user thinks that peaceful
creatures like the Dryad we're just
collateral damage 20ft pointed out that
if they had power over her elements such
as the forest then witches might feel
intimidated by this after all they do
draw their power from nature so in their
eyes a creature with that kind of power
could be dangerous Wendy thinks that's
probably something the witches wouldn't
want to deal with so
it might explain why they wanted those
sealed as well user tariffs Huerta had a
good point to this user said that
Landon's dad might be a creature that
actually lives in Malabar and there
really is no escape
so this fan thinks that maybe all three
species needed to lock this super
powerful monster inside of his own
dimension because he was a major threat
they used the three keys to keep the
creature locked away and while he does
have the power to spit creatures back
out at his own discretion he probably
cannot bring himself out into the world
he probably needs the keys to do that
super mario pro's also posed an
interesting question they were wondering
how the lab guy who is looking for wrap
and landon connected to all of this they
theorized that he could be working for
landon dad somehow through the pit and
is trying to get him out it's obvious
that he seems to know more than he's
letting on about Sayla maybe you
remembers a lot more about the pit than
he is sharing could he be Landin brother
maybe he's trying to feed these children
the way he did with landon this fan is
thinking that landon amrap are the new
Stefan and Damon or Elijah and Klaus
even if they are not related by blood
they are family and they never give up
on each other Landon's dad theory seems
absolutely plausible but could the lab
guy be his brother
how to kill a tribrid many fans are
wondering if hope is immortal one fan
has a theory about how you could
possibly end the life of a tribrid not
that anyone wants to see that happen but
it's an interesting theory this man who
goes by the handle
sanae's Ora on reddit wrote that no one
knows for sure if hopes life can
actually be ended in theory she is
mortal even if she does possess vampire
healing powers magic abilities and
werewolf resilience it certainly would
not be easy for someone to try and end
her life and even if they did try she
could just come back as a vampire and
most likely become an original hybrid
like her dad there is still a question
of if she would keep her magic if she
becomes a full vampire her existence
alone sort of breaks all the rules so
anything is possible to this fan thinks
there are one of two possible scenarios
one is that hope becomes an original
hybrid with Nomad
that would make her pretty invincible
and since there is no white oak to be
found there's nothing on the planet that
can harm her or maybe she keeps her
magic and transitions into a fully
triggered tribe read this fan thinks the
only way to get rid of hope is to throw
her into the pit of black goo but it
didn't seem to work on her after all she
did keep her memories of Selah so it's
possible she could just escape there
seems to be some disagreement among fans
about the origin of hopes healing
abilities one fan insists that her
healing powers aren't from her vampire
roots but from her werewolf side this
person believes that hope doesn't
actually manifest any vampire abilities
but another fan disagrees Reddit user
and Zetter pointed out that hope healed
quickly as a baby which was probably due
to her vampire blood apparently she will
age like a normal human
but will also have healing powers and
Zetter thinks the werewolf side helps
with that Santa Zora said that hope
doesn't have faster healing powers than
the average werewolf it seems like hopes
vampire and werewolf sides make her
pretty invincible so what do you think
is she immortal or is she at risk of
meeting her demise tell us in the
comments below what the M theory was
your favorite what do you think will
happen as season 1 comes to a close
share your best fan theories with us in
the comments section below before you go
don't forget to subscribe to the things
to be the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time